>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO COME TELL MARK
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS TO
RUN THE UNITED STATES.
BOTH PORTLAND.
NO.
THEY WANT TO RUN THE ENTIRE
THING.
ALL 50 STATES, ALL 3100
COUNTIES, ALL 320 MILLION
PEOPLE.
PROGRESSIVES WANT COMPLETE
CONTROL OF ALL OF THAT.
VERY MUCH, INCLUDING YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THAT IS THEIR GOAL IN THE COMING
ELECTION.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF THEY ACHIEVE
THAT GOAL?
WE DON'T HAVE TO ACT DUMB I
GUESS.
WE CAN ASSESS THE CITY THEY
ALREADY HAVE CONTROL OVER AND
HAVE FOR A LONG TIME.
IF THERE IS ANY COUNTRY THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO RUN, IT WOULD HAVE
TO BE SAN FRANCISCO.
IT IS A STUNNINGLY BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S A PERFECT CLIMATE.
IT HAS SOLID INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE IS A WELL EDUCATED
POPULATION.
BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING, IT HAS A
LOT OF MONEY.
SAN FRANCISCO IS ONE OF THE
RICHEST PLACES IN THE WORLD.
HOW COULD YOU SCREW THAT UP?
AND YET, TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
LEFT HAS DONE WITH
SAN FRANCISCO.
>> AND SOME SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS, HOLD YOUR NOSE
AND WATCH YOUR STEP.
>> YOU SEE PEOPLE LYING ON THE
STREETS.
YOU SEE PEOPLE PASS OUT ON THE
YOU ARE SEEN PEOPLE SHOOT UP.
YOU ARE SEEING PEOPLE EAT OUT OF
GARBAGE CANS.
>> TAKE A LOOK.
PEOPLE ARE DUMPING THEIR USED
SYRINGES INTO THE STREET.
PILES LIKE THIS ARE COMMONPLACE.
MOST OF THE NEEDLES ARE HANDED
OUT BY THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
HEALTH.
WITH NO RELIABLE WAY TO GET THEM
ALL BACK, THE CITY IS SPENDING
$750,000 TO HIRE PEOPLE TO PICK
UP THE NEEDLES.
SOME 10,000 EVERY MONTH.
>> Tucker: BOMBAY, INDIA
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THAT.
YOU WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE
AFFORDABLE, BUT IT'S THE
OPPOSITE.
AVERAGE RENT FOR AN APARTMENT IN
SAN FRANCISCO RIGHT NOW IS ABOUT
$4,000.
THE CITY WORKS ONLY FOR THE
EXTREMELY RICH.
NORMAL PEOPLE, THERE'S NO PLACE
FOR THEM.
WANT TO RAISE A FAMILY IN THE
CITY?
GOOD LUCK.
SAN FRANCISCO NOW HAS MORE
DAY CARE SPACES FOR ANIMALS THAT
IT DOES FOR BABIES.
IT IS LITERALLY A CITY WITHOUT A
FUTURE.
IT'S PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD TO
REPRODUCE.
AND SAN FRANCISCO ISN'T ALONE.
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA'S SINGLE
PARTY CITIES ARE FOLLOWING SUIT.
LOS ANGELES, FOR EXAMPLE, IS NOW
BIGGER THAN ANY CITY IN THE
ENTIRE STATE OF VERMONT.
IT'S FILTHY ENCAMPMENTS ARE
FILLED WITH DISEASES.
MORE THAN WAR-TORN COUNTRIES.
>> OVER TIME, SQUALOR BUILDS UP
ON THE STREETS, WITH RATS
FEASTING ON ROTTING FOOD MIXED
WITH SEWAGE AND USED SYRINGES.
RATS AND FLEAS, TYPHUS TRAVELED
THROUGH THE STREETS.
THE ATTORNEY, WHO WORKS WAY UP
ON THE SIXTH FLOOR OF CITY HALL,
GOT INFECTED.
>> I FELT LIKE I WAS GOING TO
DIE.
>> GREENWOOD SAID THAT THE CITY
HAS ALWAYS HAD RATS, BUT WHAT
HASN'T CHANGED IS WHAT'S AROUND
IT.
>> THE HOMELESS POPULATION HAS
MOVED CLOSER AND CLOSER.
THEY SURROUND THE BUILDING.
SO, AS FOLKS WALK TO WORK AND
BACK, THEY ARE WALKING THROUGH
ROTTING FOOD, RAW SEWAGE.
>> Tucker: TYPHUS?
WHAT COUNTRY IS THIS?
WHO DID THIS?
THEY DID THE SAME THING TO
SACRAMENTO.
THAT'S THE STATE CAPITAL OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT HAS GOTTEN SO OUT OF CONTROL
THAT ORDINARY PEOPLE CAN BARELY
LIVE THERE.
>> I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN I GET TO WORK.
I HAVE TO CLEAN UP THE AND OFF
OF MY DOORSTEP.
I HAVE TO CLEAN UP THE SYRINGES.
I HAVE TO FIGHT OFF PEOPLE THAT
PUSH THEIR WAY INTO MY SHOP THAT
ARE HOMELESS AND ON DRUGS,
BECAUSE YOU WON'T ARREST THEM
FOR DRUG OFFENSES.
I HAVE TO APOLOGIZE TO MY
CLIENTS.
SO I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO FOR US, THE ONES
THAT ARE UNHAPPY.
YOU WANT TO MAKE IT A SANCTUARY
STATE.
YOU WANT TO MAKE IT COMFORTABLE
FOR EVERYONE EXCEPT FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK HARD AND HAVE
TRIED THEIR HARDEST TO GET ALONG
IN LIFE.
WHY YOU SIT IN YOUR MILLION
DOLLAR HOME AND YOU DON'T HAVE
TO LOOK AT WHAT WE ARE LOOKING
AT, THERE ARE HARDWORKING PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
US ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> Tucker: IT'S A DISASTER,
OBVIOUSLY.
AND YET, REMARKABLY, CITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY, ARE RACING
TO COPY CALIFORNIA.
WASHINGTON, D.C., IS NOW COVERED
WITH TENTS AND FELT.
DRIVE AROUND IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE IT.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE.
FOR DECADES, AMERICANS FLED
CITIES TO ESCAPE FROM CHAOS AND
CRIME.
FINALLY, IN THE 1990s, CRIME
FELL.
IT BECAME LIVABLE AGAIN.
PROPERTY VALUES ROSE.
POOR NEIGHBORHOODS GOT BETTER.
EVERYONE BENEFITED, AND PEOPLE
STARTED MOVING BACK.
PLACES THAT HAD BEEN TREKKING
FOR DECADES, PLACES LIKE
WASHINGTON AND PHILADELPHIA,
STARTED GROWING AGAIN.
IT WAS A SUCCESS.
BUT THAT IS GOING IN REVERSE NO
NOW.
AMONG AMERICAN'S SEVEN LARGEST
CITIES, SAN FRANCISCO HAS THE
HIGHEST PROPERTY LEVEL CRIME
LEVELS.
THERE ARE 70 CAR BREAK-INS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THAT IS ENABLED BY RAPID.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, AMERICA'S
LIBERAL CITIES SIDE WITH THE
CRIMINALS.
IN DALLAS COUNTY, TEXAS, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
THERE IS REFUSING TO CRIMINALLY
PROSECUTE THEFTS OF LESS THAN
$750.
HE DECIDES THAT THEFT WAS OF
NECESSARY ITEMS.
HE BELIEVES THAT AMERICAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
"SYSTEMATICALLY RACIST."
SO, HE HAS STOPPED PROVIDING
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT ALL.
THAT IS A CATEGORY THAT INCLUDES
BURGLARY.
NOT SO LOW-LEVEL IF YOU ARE THE
VICTIM OF THAT.
THEY ARE NOT HARD TO PREDICT.
YOU KNOW EXACT WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN YOU GOVERN LIKE
THIS.
IN FACT, IT HAS HAPPENED.
IN 2018, PHILADELPHIA HAD ITS
HIGHEST MURDER RECORD IN A
DECADE.
IT HAS DRAMATICALLY SURGED IN A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT CITIES WITH
SIMILAR PROGRAMS.
CHICAGO, BALTIMORE, WASHINGTON.